we have already expressed our very
serious concerns about the situation the
situation has not improved we are of
course working with all our member
states to have common firm response to
those in development today there will be
Foreign Affairs Council and very soon
the heads of state and government of
Europe will also need to have common
response many contacts have been taking
place with the Ukrainian authorities and
also with the Russian authorities
because we believe it's very important
to show our commitment to the
sovereignty of Ukraine at the same time
we are now preparing a package of
support to Ukraine we are working with
IMF and myself and European Commission
are preparing some options for a
supporting Ukraine we as we said we keep
our willingness to offer you crying the
political association economic
integration through the association
agreement and also the sweet trade
agreement but there are some
difficulties left-handed which we have
to respond through emergency measures so
this is the point work in the economic
field well as a matter of urgency trying
to articulate with all our parties
internationally support for their
country but also politically to do our
everything that you can to avoid the
escalation and provide the lack of
respect for the
sovereignty of Ukraine and I believe
this is shared by all European countries
we will see this today when they meet at
funguses Minister left